Người dân trả nệm dưới đường, đỡ những người nhẹ khỏi khách sản đăng trảy ở ẩn đồ.
Theo Rhoiter's, lắm trảy mục lên trước chính giờ ngày 3 thằng sấu, tại một toàn nhà ở Umang Vian đã ra phía năm
như đi lì video hịt chường cho thấy lửa và hỏi bao chụt các tình trên trong khi nhiều người mắc kẹt đi các thấp hình.
Nhà lập khóc điện nương xa phí xu và đi ra cho biết khách sản có bún bệnh lưu chú khi hỏng sử ra.
Cảy ra xác nhận ít nhất 2 mốt người triển mạch, chuyến thông ấn đổi cho biết,
người tảm nạn nhân là người nước ngoài mang quốc tịch các nước châu Phi.
Lực lượng kiểu vộ đã đưa hình bún mươi ra hỏi toàn nhà và chuyển họ tới các mình viện gần đó.
Theo điều tra sơ vộ của sự cứ hỏi đây li, các sạch không có dễ chính nhận an toàn không trảy.
Giám đất di ngoả, a cao mà liết cho biết, toàn nhà không có cửa sồ chỉ có một lối ra vào,
khiến việc hất nạn gặp nhiều khó khăn, lắm trảy được cho là bắt muồn ử tình thầm.
Giới làm nên các ấn trên, tân hầm bị trảm bằng cửa quân, bột lĩnh yếu ngoả phải có lẽ tiếp cận.
Đây là một trong những uống trảy nghiêm trọng nước tại hủ đổ and đổ trong những năm gần đây,
hủ đứng narên ra môi đi, hỏi vụ việc là một thạm việc, nguyên nhân mạch vạch đang được điều tra.